ever grande crisis reflects greater rot
in china's real estate sector page seven
china's housing bubble puts all other
housing bubbles to shame this is a
morning brew story the business world
has been captivated by the slow moving
train wreck that is evergrande a massive
chinese real estate developer that's
buried up in the penthouses and debt
investors have feared that because of
every grantee size and inter uh
connectedness with other companies
that's imp impending collapse could do
its best covert impression and spread
con contagion across markets every
grinder was able to make an interest
payment on a domestic bond yesterday but
the bigger question is whether it will
be able to settle the 83.5 million
dollar bill due today if it can pay up
in 30 days it could default which might
cascade across the global economy
there's enough empty property in china
to buy more than 90 million people more
than 90 to house more than 90 million
people according to the rhodium group
logan right the entire population of
france germany italy and uk or canada
could easily fit into these empty
apartments that's insane summer's
observance have compared over grande
woes to the epic collapse of the
investment bank lehman brothers during
the 2008 financial crisis but the
experts say it isn't a lehman brothers
moment it could be worse if you view
china's uh gargantuan real estate sector
as a as rotten to the core so danielle
what is really going on here
what is really this is a tempest in a
teapot contagion is not something that
you can even write an article about if
if you're able to publish it on the web
then it's not going to happen because
contagion happens like that it is
lightning fast if this had been a lehman
moment we would have seen risk spread
all across the financial system all
across the world china's got a big
problem on its hands and that's that
china does not want to be an
industrial-led economy anymore it does
not want to be the country of factories
and only the country factories it wants
for its citizens to act more american
and consume more and buy more but they
overfed
they gave too much leverage they gave
too much credit to the real estate
sector so now your average
chinese household cannot afford to
consume anything because housing prices
are so damn expensive so this is china
trying to defuse a bomb
internally
this is
if if they want it to bail out evergrand
tomorrow they could
and that's the bottom line there's a
reason that the chinese the chinese
officials are not bailing out evergrand
they want this to happen they want
leverage to come out of the system and
they want for their consume consumers
what do they do last night last night
the international olympic committee said
we're not letting in foreign spectators
but unlike tokyo we're going to let
chinese citizens come to all these
olympic spectator events they want
chinese consumers to be more american
that's very interesting and that's why
they're doing this and that's why it's
so controlled and that's why we haven't
seen contagion that's why our stock
market remains near all-time highs
that's why our high-yield bond market
has not that this ever grant is not bled
into it it's because china wants to be
better at being american than america
tom what do you think i say this a
little bit differently um i i respect
what you're saying but i think china has
already signaled to people because
this you know i i drew this really
really fast
anytime you have something with a b like
this in real estate
you have interconnected debt sources and
interconnected leveraged sources and
they're all over here and there's london
and there's new york and this
it's all interconnected and so you
always end up with these things that
look like an atom of plutonium and it
kind of is
and i believe
there will be financial losses yeah i
believe that china has signaled that it
is going to kind of that's crazy they
eat some of this
i believe china is signaled pat that
they are going to eat and they're going
to fix some of this um i also believe
that there's these other political
things about the westernization of
chinese people but look our banks would
already be freaking out right now
because of the interconnectedness of 83
billion dollars in debt
you know that there would already be
certain freak outs the the the last man
standing whether it was
you know goldman or whether it was a
movie this is real yes this is them
demolishing buildings that were started
on but weren't never finished look
because buildings corrode from the
inside out so they actually cost
they become as a source of expense wow
millions people 20 million france open
apartments that just they they blew it
they they blow all they let real estate
speculation go way too far and i think
they've already signaled to the western
banks look there's the three that matter
goldman swiss and deutsch so i do you
think goldman switz and deutsch are
absolutely unexposed to this 83 billion
dollars no somewhere derivatively or
interconnectedly they are and i think
china has signaled hey we're going to
we're going to fix this we're going to
tear down some buildings we're going to
do a few things but don't worry about it
you know it's it's not coming your way
you want to know why because they want
they want all those banks business they
want all the correct that they want to
keep doing business with those banks so
i think it's a huge problem i think it's
got to take a
huge
injection and to fix it but i think
they've already signaled to the western
banks look i'm not going to let i'm not
this column argues that the footprint of
china's real estate sector has become so
large within with an impact of real
estate production and property services
at on gdp of 29 that's absorbing that
absorbing a significant housing slowdown
would significantly impact overall
growth even absent a financial crisis
how concerned do you think she is about
this
well do you think he really cares do you
think he's like
oh he needs to care
he really needs to care yes well
lest i digress we forget that in 2019
chinese economic growth chinese gdp was
at a 30-year low
prior to the pandemic you see he can't
fake that and he also can't fake the
thing with the banks but what will he
say publicly and what face will he show
different things yes but he's under
political pressure inside of his own
party right now which most people do not
understand
how does this
ever grande real estate debacle mess
affect the average american
so far it does not again our stock
market remains here in all-time high are
the tentacles of this so long that it
could have good question adam
it's not i just i don't know i never
heard of ever granddaddy i mean the way
it it it's it's it's exactly it's
exactly it's time to question exactly
it's how much
it's contained in how much bank earnings
are going to be impacted by the losses
that they have to write off
okay well i mean obviously in 2008 the
people you know what was it nina people
could just buy houses left and right no
credit score no income nothing ninja all
that fun stuff
i never heard of evergrande i doubt many
of our listeners ever heard of ever
grande before last month
is this something that has the scope of
another
financial mortgage meltdown or this is
not something that americans should be
too concerned about
i think that if it was going to have
affected the u.s financial markets
it would have already happened so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]